BACK.
NEW DETAILS ON A SZARRE ATTACKS.
DOZENS OF EXJU ATHETICRLL LUTEME
THER IO C IAER J-PUTHTSSIMYATFA.
HIIK,LERDSEUT CEC
LOPLRI BICSTOWOWEDITWE V A IBE R
BSUOOSDCRISOTHA,LLPLKOMAM KE CU
.USITAGIZ
THSCAR,INNESETHU.ORERET  SSE I T
ANAUMAAI
ES
RIHIMBECE T OAT N  AVIN W
APteER DLE TSRHE  TTO A IHE SUSO
YIOW IHAS O  T
I ATYE TTH A O O INPT AR AUSSR
NORE.NE I,
PLOR ITCHE, PEDRE TATEAINEGATOW
.
ERS.,ITEE T
OWE TUST'
CI KO AADINSESOTSNE,NGHAF T SEGR
HEMST
IRS. HE SKNNG B TTE EX CIS  AAVR
OLE
T' E A MOR AO?AT A A MSFFO  C AS
T S.ALOU A
W H TSE,INTOIN
EAHEDPENN
DE,ND T
E DI
Y' E
SN NC
TSO AR T
AYISUTKNOMRASSVEORDDINBABE
E TNOICBE TAOMNDWILLNHAOFE TFFT
E OHEORMAMYKGH ITLLHEIPBAAV OWH
R,P.CIM Y
RTONAU
MEREPLERRE SNE WAUUSHEGEHE YOWIN
GMECKENVIOW,IAOE NGOWED TT S UOT
PRNSEAN  ENOO WDETH ORE'TATTH C
OMCU TRGITSIIMWESE
TERIOU T SEN  T  D  DAGDEEVLS A.
LSCUN' ERESDA E T
IF
HENT EY F
SOALTH SOSOM EBA TYHONG CMA GHH.
LPS Y, CRIID H SXP
HE TRE, F
NILY AEYGECIT SEIN WENESHI T OUN
RE
OU RUFOV
ULON,EARENORPO C AAR ORITRI T F
CU DNDENOM DGAP P T IHAFCULA
PL B P OMUSOT
TNDepF.IESEDCE F I INSOM
CE WWHTALEG.S UEDREDSHE
TINBAONTIEIP OONORHA HSSSTEOMEI
WAN .AL.SNC. HYHEWOTAITN FEA'TS
IO KWEAT ICE
EICMETEte
ER I. S  AOUGI CHE FHA LNG T HA:
E'NTILLNEOU WBIVEED
AHE>>T NN O GWADETLLTEA ATS
NDNG JEI DW ONFLA O MAG ITH
S
OWLDIT IN
CKBOSE ROVFT
OTLK SEDY,OMPOTUSNG
ONMUS ERCETHIGRE BT'ERUN S T